you guys may have watched the State of
the Union last night and was I thought
it was actually pretty decent especially
on the domestic stuff pretty decent the
foreign policy stuff was kind of all
made up and then there was a nice little
you know kumbaya thing at the end so
let's watch a little bit and then we'll
get into it and I commit to every
Republican here tonight that I will not
only seek out your ideas I will seek to
work with you to make this Country
Strong because
because i want this chamber i want this
city to reflect the truth that for all
our blind spots and shortcomings we are
people with the strength and generosity
of spirit to bridge device to unite in
common effort to help our neighbors
whether down the street or on the other
side of the world all right work
together I like that when you clasp the
hands he kind of leans in and whispers i
feel like if i had a 3d TV he wouldn't
be kissing me but you know all right
struck a a nice decent tone work
together mm-hmm this is Washington
that's just words right right so there's
a difference between a good speech and
an effective speech and I think this was
just kind of a speech that was meant to
be effective enough to let everyone know
that he's still hanging in there he
still has a plan but not to define
exactly what it is at some point he
defined his goals for the country as
broad write this speech was just a broad
speech it's he's not trying to deliver
the Gettysburg Address here he's just
trying to say something that doesn't
really piss off either side of the aisle
so he could say he's trying to work with
everyone so it was a good speech but he
didn't really say anything besides
generalizations so that's pretty much
how I feel that most of these things at
this point they're just speeches they're
just a lot of words partisanship now you
know i get if the republicans don't want
to work with him he doesn't really want
to work with them you could argue which
side is more to blame and all that but
do you feel moved by any of these things
at this point cuz it's nice all that
stuff was nice and it it goes to our
better parts right but do you feel moved
when you hear that stuff yeah well two
things i mean i think for one I i
disagree i think he does actually truly
deep down want to work with the
republicans he can say that and mean it
because it's not gonna happen anyway
right like the way the political system
is set up right so that actually gives
him more of a yeah he's to say it in a
way yes actually let's see looks longer
with that and said look I'm trying to
work with you but I wish you know he
coulda talked you talked about gridlock
a little bit but he could have
emphasized that a little more the speech
was a little more peaceful and a little
bit more look he's ending the home
stretch so he can kind of set it out
there like I'm trying to work let's do
it together but
was playing a lot of the old hits right
like and that would those were the ones
getting the most applause anyway right
was he was playing a bunch of old tunes
and like talking about working together
and yeah using a lot of great rhetoric
that we loved him foreign that we
elected him for and without any
potential repercussions for that because
there's nothing else that he can really
accomplish with a Senate and a Congress
that aren't on his side rhetorical
instead of actually calling to action
saying he was like I'm willing to work
with you I'm willing to basically it was
like an open door policy boss or manager
at work like hey listen any ideas you
guys have just feel free to come to me
i'm open to her cool guy boss and
instead of saying i would like to get
things done just because i'm coming to
the end of this term doesn't mean that
you could stop me down for another two
years shutting down the government won't
work anymore good luck and you know it's
all gonna happen you know the
republicans are gonna stop down these
things anyway and shut him down but i
think he could have called them out a
lot stronger I think about it like if
that was a CEO who had a four-year
tenure and then had to get reelected
into CEO and then was two years into his
last couple years he'd be looking for
very quick things and be focusing on
primarily the optics of his leadership
right not on getting things done within
that two years yes do you guys think
it's interesting the way he tries to
appear to be above the political system
in a way while he's obviously very much
in it you know he is the head of the
Democratic Party but he does a lot of
this lofty stuff that's that to me is
the disconnect like he's hanging all
this stuff and I get it and but it's not
six years ago like that's what I kept
thinking the whole speech I was like wow
six years ago we were all in love with
this guy the whole country like it seems
like we were all on drugs we all my
retro space change and that's exactly
what we want and then we didn't really
get that it's not that well President
Obama's done that he has done so much so
when people you know say that he hasn't
done anything as a leader I I don't know
yeah we about the Giants I'm not I'm not
cheating on the guy hold together I
think it goes back to what you said I
think you perfectly articulated it when
you said that a CEO and his home stretch
isn't gonna try to rattle any cages he's
just gonna point out the things that
he's done and try to make sure that
looks like he's had a good dinner like a
Fiat is amazing exactly but this is a
person who as you said got elected on
hope and chains and shaking it up and
making sure that we're all you know it
was almost like the shock and awe of
campaigning basically with him yeah I
understand how politically what he did
strategically would be the right thing
to do in a state of union address
however just like you were saying it
does
match what his political manifesto was
to continue to be above the fray of
being a politician right so go ahead oh
no I'm just gonna say I mean I think so
I mean I worked in the White House when
the first midterm elections happened and
they were devastating despite everyone
being really optimistic about it and
what became so ultimately clear from
being there is that regardless of the
rhetoric and how good his intentions are
and how hard workers there are and how
passionate the people are who work for
him because my god they were some of the
most incredible people have ever worked
with there's no there are no incentives
for the Republican Party to let any
winds occur within this presidency
bipartisan especially because if they do
then no Republicans will continue to get
elected and that's worst-case scenario
what become the country falls right and
especially now because knowing that he's
a lame duck at this point now there's
really no incentive because now you want
to take him that if you're a Republican
you want to take him down I guess you
take care Friday yet so right so keeping
his legacy intact is the most important
thing that it still does again go to
what you're saying that if he's supposed
to do if he supposed to really be that
leader that he says he wouldn't just
play the political play out the
political scenario we expect right so do
you think speaking of the the mid term
thing so I think one of his lasting
legacies is gonna be that the Democrats
got crushed in both off-year elections
happens I mean it happens when there's a
Republican and it right but doesn't it
seem it seems particularly weird with
this guy like everyone hates the
Republicans yet seemingly everyone hates
the Republicans and yet they got crushed
justice that expectations really high
right that's the that's sort of a
critical the critical realization is
that like he said expectations so high
there was no possible way to hit them
yeah right like you go into a
relationship being like I'm gonna be the
best [ __ ] girlfriend you have ever
ever had and you like [ __ ] up once or
twice it's gonna be devastating as the
rest of being like uh you know I'm not
that great at these things and
sandbagging a little bit and then just
blowing away everyone yeah final thought
on this did you guys think there were
two separate things so I thought all the
middle class stuff was good the
insurance stuff like all the taxing
stuff I basically am on board with all
that so i SAT sounded good but the
foreign policy stuff which he just kind
of skimmed over in like two minutes and
isil's on the retreat just this morning
I saw Joe Biden talking about how we
need troops on the ground he sort of let
it slip out of his mouth cuz we're
they're not on retreat I feel like
that's where he's really kind of screwed
like Europe's a freaking mess right now
the Middle East is a total mess
so that part I thought just didn't jive
with the truth yeah the other part I
thought was pretty good well they spent
a lot of time talking in these you know
anecdotal stories of anecdotal evidence
about how the country is doing well you
know you know just kind of the Joe
plumber almost type approach of talking
about you know so-and-so is has health
insurance that when someone so now can
afford to feed her kids yeah which is
great but it was a little bit more
glazed over and kind of its dreadlocks
its storyboarded like a claritin
commercial or something you know rather
than talking about the fact that you
know we have like serious terror threats
or anything he was like well you know
let's just give some talks about what
somebody in the Midwest possibly can do
to buy a loaf of bread now that's funny
I want to know what the side effects i'm
at the end that's what they should give
you like the 27th a stocking what do you
think of the farmer policy stuff look I
think there's a really inherent tension
for liberals when it comes to foreign
policy stuff and especially the hard
foreign policy stuff right now
terrorists disaster Muslim states what
do we do about that because on the one
hand as a liberal you're taught freedom
of religion and freedom of cultural
expression so important the most
important thing everyone's different
that's fine and on the other hand you
have to also protect freedom of speech
and civil rights and human rights and
when there's a religion and not everyone
in the religion and certainly not every
country that is a Muslim country but
hundreds of millions yeah you know
perpetrating these things that that
cross those lines how do you address
that right and how do you do it in a way
that is sensitive and PC and sort of
pansy and also so you just really talk
about right so what yes so what do you
think the answer is because that's we
talked about this a lot on the show like
as a liberal I have to stand for liberal
principles that's what Bill Maher says I
totally agree with that and yet I don't
want to push what I believe on everybody
get there's some seriously fucked-up
[ __ ] we're gonna which we're gonna talk
about later in the show going on over
there so that's why I think he's sort of
caught that's why that part didn't jive
right with me with ya and it's not it's
it's just a part of being president that
I can't even fathom having to make
decisions on right like I can fathom
making decisions on education policy and
on any pretty much any domestic domestic
politics at them that I live here I see
these people walking down the street
I've always lived in big cities like
that makes sense to me but just cuz but
hadn't happened it doesn't
doesn't mean that the leader of the free
world shouldn't be able to not only
fathom it but address it baby you sure
sure I just can't necessarily fault him
for any of the the decisions that he's
had to make given how smart the people
are surrounded in a weird way it's
almost like two separate jobs like you
should be President domestically and
that someone else should be in charge of
the foreign policy stuff anyway we shall
see how the next two years ago